well thanks for having me as Matt shared
my name is cat Berman and today I'd like
to take you on what I call the journey
of other and what I mean by other is
that feeling that I bet most of us in
this room have had of feeling different
of feeling not in the in-group feeling
the minority and I don't mean the
obvious other you know the one that
nightmares are made of where you're
standing in front of the class and I'm
naked and you're all laughing at me I
mean the more subtle other that many is
if many of us have felt perhaps because
the color of our skin or perhaps the
Witsel the way we say a word with a
particular accent could be because of
the car our parents drove the clothing
choice we decided to make today I'm
talking about that feeling of other that
is nuanced that perhaps no one around
you even knows you feel and yet you feel
it and it can make you feel defensive it
can make you feel mad and sometimes it
just makes us feel lonely so I'd like to
share with you my journey of others and
how its shaped the person I am how its
challenged me in very interesting ways
and how truly it has been beneficial to
me as an entrepreneur in my hoax that
today you can perhaps see a little bit
of your other and how it is shaping you
as the professional entrepreneur I think
many of you are and are going to be so
let me start with my other I grew up in
a predominantly Argentine family and so
what that means is I was a very alive in
a very Argentine household my mother is
a first generation immigrant from what a
situs and so growing up we had a lot of
this we had a lot of meat a lot of
chimichurri we ate dinner at nine
o'clock at night spoke tons of Spanish
we would enjoy each other's very
loud barbecues asados we would do things
like drink mathy which is the tea there
if you've been there right after school
I'd run home in the morning
I've run home you know mid at midday and
drink my day which we now know is way
too much caffeine and sugar for a kid at
that age but at the time I loved it
and so we had these wonderful traditions
of living what felt like a boy no siteís
household in the middle of Southern
California and nothing felt strange to
me until about second grade and it's
really in second grade that I started
knowing some differences things like I'd
kids come over my house and complain
when it became 6:00 or 6:30 that my mom
had not fed them dinner I even had one
kid threatened to call his parents
saying that my mom was starving her
because it was 6:30 and she still had no
food and how dare my mom treat her like
this what was our deal and again we ate
98 dinner at 9 o'clock at night the
other difference I felt was when we
started speaking Spanish at school and I
would you say things that if you have
any argentine friends you know we speak
a little bit differently and I would say
things like show and Bushell local and
see chefs and that wasn't quite the
Spanish that they were teaching in my
Southern California class and then
lastly to give you another example
probably one of the most awkward moments
is when kids started to call my house
asking for me and they would get my
abuela who lived with us and didn't
speak a lot of English and so when I
would get on the phone really
well-intentioned and try to communicate
and get this little kids you know what
if they're looking for and she would ask
in her broken English and finally pass
the phone to me in which case I had to
respond to that awkward question of Oh
was that your maid
no that was my abuela yep she lived in
the United States but doesn't really
speak a lot of English and yes she lives
with us
not over the weekends not over the
summers she lives with us and so those
subtle differences started giving me
that feeling of others and I sometimes
liking it too if you've had an Advil ho
day which is this amazing treat if you
haven't had this I'm sorry
let's get you one it's that feeling of
being swish squished in between two
cultures and on one side there was an
American culture that I was smack in the
middle of as a kid but I loved it that
was so exciting and then I had this
beautiful Argentine culture that I'd
come to love and felt very connected to
and yet when I went to school I didn't
want to be Argentine I wanted to be in I
wanted to be the majority I didn't want
to be other and so that secret sense of
other came to build and build and so I
effectively spent the next several years
of my elementary school junior high high
school learning how to not be other and
for those of you who've experienced this
you've probably learned some what I call
the ninja skills or the double agent
skills that I did which is you learn to
observe really well right
you walk into a new situation you can
kind of gather who's the popular kid or
who's the mean kid or read a room right
you learn what the trends are gonna be
because you want to make sure you don't
miss out on those you learn what not to
do so you don't stand out so all of
these skills I call double agent skills
because at the same time I knew I had
different backgrounds but I still so
desperately wanted to not be other and
so by the time high school was over and
I went to college I had effectively
created this amazing ability to just be
no one knew no one knew that I would had
any Argentine blood no one really knew
there was anything other about me in
other ways shapes or forms
I was wholeheartedly good at playing
that me to role and so when I was time
for college I thought I got this I know
this I feel in I know this game were
good so I showed up to my school in
Boston and as a very international
school so I thought well that's not
going to be a problem I've already got
that
I was very excited until it was in the
first couple weeks of school I lived in
the freshman dorms I realized quite
quickly it almost everybody on my dorm
room floor was insanely wealthy and it's
not like I came from poverty but we were
not wealthy and certainly not insanely
wealthy and one of my favorite stories
from that time was one of my first
shopping journey is with a couple
girlfriends from my floor and so we went
to this major mall in Boston and we're
all getting winter apparel and I
remember getting excited to get a pair
of gloves and these two friends start
buying and buying and buying and buying
and buying and we literally leave this
shopping complex and they've got bags
bags and bags of clothes and so I say to
them wow how much did that cost just out
of pure curiosity and one of my friends
and I will never forget this looks at me
and goes cat I never look at the bill I
just sign and I remember thinking to
myself oh my god
this is a different world I have just
entered a world that I've never known
but most of the people I went to college
with lived and breathed and so if you
can imagine kind of what's next for
somebody who was a scholarship kid there
I had to get a job if I was gonna keep
up with these friends who had no
spending limit I had to get a job and I
remember my first job in college very
very well in fact painfully well because
I worked at a piece-of-crap restaurant
which was essentially the Student Union
restaurant so I want you to imagine with
me and I don't know if you have this at
Stanford but something that is supposed
to be a restaurant that feels kind of
cool and kind of different but yet no
ambiance serves the same crappy food you
get in your dorms just charges you a
little bit more and gives you a cloth
napkin
and that's where I got my first
waitressing job in college and so I was
excited to have a job and I was excited
to be making money but I won't lie I was
embarrassed because my friends would go
out on a Thursday night and talk about
the bar scene they were gonna go and hop
from Party to party and I had to figure
out how I was going to avoid telling
them that I was gonna go to this lousy
place to earn my first dollars and so I
figured out a couple different really
creative ways you know I'd tell them I
was going to the library
I would say that I was doing some
extracurricular activity all kinds of
interesting creative stories I could
make up to avoid telling my friends who
didn't have to work that not only was i
working but I was working in a place
that was miserable and I was pretty
embarrassed about and so that was pretty
much the cadence of my freshman year of
a lot of trying to dodge the other so I
could fit in and feel like I was part of
this community and yet something really
fascinating happened to me
towards the end of that freshman year
beginning of my sophomore year and I
call it a closer look and I think many
of you have probably experienced this so
let me share what I mean by that when I
was growing up I had friends and I'd go
to their house for dinner or I'd have
the occasional slumber party to my mom's
chagrin because esto no se hacen had in
viña so we didn't do a lot of summer
parties but I finally talked her into
letting me do some slumber parties and
you'd go and you'd meet the parents and
you meet the siblings but you didn't
really have a sense of what was going on
in that other person's world or at least
I didn't as a kid and so I figured
everybody's life is perfect perfect
little Americans something happened that
freshman year and perhaps it was living
on the same floor day by day with the
same people many of whom actually
invited me to their houses for holidays
and spring break and I got a closer look
about what it was actually happening in
their lives and I learned two really
really important thing
number one I learned nearly everyone has
that sense of other for example three of
my closest friends one incredibly
wealthy I shared you the story of her
just signing their way and so on the
peripheral or just you know
superficially you think she's got it all
she wants for nothing
incredibly incredibly unhappy she would
come home in the holidays to two parents
who couldn't stand each other who had
been on the verge of divorce for years
who had both worked separately and done
tremendously well in their jobs but had
nothing left to give to the family or
each other
and so all this wealth that she had
amassed and that she enjoyed spending
came in a price very wealthy and very
unhappy my other friend gorgeous to date
gorgeous gorgeous woman and she would
always dress perfectly perfectly cloth
you know perfectly made-up and I would
look at her like wow that's gotta be so
cool to walk in a room and have that
presence and have that at those looks
and Wow
until I got a closer look and came to
learn that this wonderful woman who was
so beautiful
was so insecure she had been struggling
with an eating disorder for years she
had a family that cared a lot about
looks and behind-the-scenes when she
took off all her makeup she was
incredibly depressed and the third
friend very ambitious young lady was
actually my college roommate her father
had told her that she is very smart and
should pursue something very exciting
and so when I met her for the first time
she said oh I'm definitely a computer
science major it's in my family I'm very
focused I'm very ambitious and so we
were all absolutely inspired by her
freshman year that she was just so
driven and so with the closer look I
came to find was actually her dad who
wanted her to be the computer science
major not her and he was back home
struggling with cancer and she didn't
want to let him down
left to her own devices she wanted to do
something completely different but she
felt the weight of the world of her
father of that struggle of losing her
father that she kept up that front but
this is actually what she wanted to do
and so I share those stories because we
all have those stories and so or during
that time of a closer looked look I
really found that we all feel to some
degree that sense of other and we all
have choices and so that's what really
happened to me my sophomore year is I
recognized wow this exterior of
perfection actually doesn't exist and
we're all struggling with that sense of
other and what we do with that matters
that we can choose to shine a light on
our other and just ignore it and keep up
the facade or we can choose to shine a
light on it and seek to understand it
look at it through a lens of what do I
value what do I care about who do I want
to be and do I want to continue to
embrace what I was born with or what
I've accepted to date or do I want to go
another path and that was a huge moment
for me because I decided there were a
lot of parts of me that were other and
it was something that I chose to be
proud of and not hide anymore and so
from that point my college career took a
very different turn I started doing a
lot more things I started actually being
very vocal about the fact I had to work
and proud about the fact that I was
earning my own money and was very
independent I dumped that lousy job in
the student restaurant and tried some
new jobs some funnier than others and
one of my favorite ended up being an
interview for a cocktail waitress and so
I had rumored I'd heard it rumored that
cocktail waitresses made much more money
than regular waitresses and so I was
dubious about the whole
things but I thought I'm just gonna
check this out so there was a cocktail
bar more kind of a dive bar in Harvard
Square it had put out an ad saying come
this Tuesday we're gonna be interviewing
for cocktail waitresses you'll be making
X amount of money incredible tips
sounded larger than life so I thought
I'm a curious cat I'll go over there so
I went met the manager he looked me up
and down and then he said to me okay so
here's how we do it what I do is I
invite the girls that I like to come and
waitress on Saturday all eight of you at
the very same time and whoever at the
end of that Saturday night has amounted
the most tips will get the job that's
simple and I love a good challenge so I
thought all right look at try this out
and then as I'm walking out the door and
I remember this like it was yesterday he
says to me oh by the way I recommend you
wear a short skirt a low top and heels
so as I shared I like a good challenge
so I took that information back and I
came back that Saturday wearing long
pants a turtleneck to here and guess who
got the job so for me I had decided that
I was proud of the woman I was that I
knew I could sell and I knew I could be
personal and I thought I could damn well
get that job without having to objectify
myself and so I was gonna go for it and
so that embracing of that side of me
that refused to be what was expected of
me was the first along a long series of
other challenges I would face but it was
something that came out of that sense of
being proud of my other so after college
as many of my friends move to big cities
chasing big paychecks
I decided to move to Puerto Rico and
served in AmeriCorps for a year I had
always had a very deep feeling of social
justice and probably coming from you
know a background of seeing a lot of
things and wanted to use my Spanish in a
way I thought could do some social good
so I moved to Puerto Rico and instantly
experienced
another delightful period of other so I
spoke Spanish could definitely relate to
folks and yet every single person in my
30 person AmeriCorps office called me
Ginga and wanted nothing to do with me
because from their impression I was the
rich American coming down and nothing to
give it they didn't know nothing to do
with what was going on in their place
and so that feeling of isolation and
loneliness of other despite trying to do
good creeped right back in front of me
and so I will stop and say that one year
in Puerto Rico as a recent college
graduate was one of the most challenging
years of my entire life to date why to
give some examples I'm there for two
weeks our supervisor of this of these 30
folks in this in this barrack or
department who had been revered and one
of the reasons I chose that part of the
AmeriCorps experience down there decides
to leave so now we're without supervisor
and complete chaos the next six months
our whole office had weekly turnarounds
of new supervisors and cuting including
a few drug addicts and alcoholics amidst
them secondly I was sent down there to
start a literacy program in a couple
months time I was gonna I was told I had
to start homelessness program in a
couple months time I was told I was now
gonna be doing an economic development
program and about halfway through my
AmeriCorps experience Hurricane George
hit now hurricane George's nothing as
bad as what we've just seen but imagine
being someone who has never experienced
a hurricane I come from earthquake
country it was crazy it was frightening
and after we got over the other side of
it I now became a translator for FEMA
see FEMA at the time had not sent down
enough bilingual translators and so many
poor parts of the island were destroyed
and so I got in a truck and my hard hat
and toured Puerto Rico trying to help as
much as I can bring relief to these
families a lot of the challenges of that
year had to do with that feeling that
feeling of being different that feeling
of not being accepted despite really
good intentions but what I learned from
all that and for any of you who can
relate and have come out on the other
side is you learn such a thick skin so
much resilience not to let what people
say about you define who you are
lastly I'll share one of my favorite
experiences from Puerto Rico which was
one of the women who didn't like me in
the office because I was you know coming
from the mainland decided to start a
rumor that I was sleeping with one of
the other workers husbands who by the
way was 20 years my senior and so I
ended up confronting this woman who
started the rumor we ended up getting
into an incredible exchange and by the
end of my one year experience was
actually an incredibly good friend to
date I've contacted her for hurricane
relief in Puerto Rico but again starting
from that place of challenge being able
to move to a place of compassion what
was she thinking and fearing that would
cause her to do this going to a place of
direct communication and then coming out
the other side
was not easy but absolutely was worth it
and so from Puerto Rico I decided to
move to New York so now I had a degree
in marketing I was gonna go use it I'd
done some good in the world and so
unlike many of my friends who had gone
for careers in cosmetics and fashion I
always loved technology I thought it was
so much more interesting than toothpaste
or makeup and so I ended up getting a
job at this great marketing firm and
joining their tech team
and not shocking to most of you in the
room only women CEO is the man all my
team members are guys and all my clients
we're gentlemen well I shouldn't say
gentlemen guys it's a good segue into
this story and so one of my first
experiences working in New York and
working in this firm was the CEO flew me
down
to San Antonio where we were pitching a
robotics company really cool robotics
company folks from NASA amazing guys
we're gonna get the front of them this
was the last conversation to close the
deal represent them and it was just me
and the CEO of this firm and I remember
walking in to a table with four white
gentlemen many of them at that point
probably thirty years my senior and I
walk in and I've got my suit and I look
very young but I'm trying to look very
professional and I walk in and the
gentleman says to me great so you're
here to take our coffee order right the
CEO had not come in yet so he didn't
know and so without hesitation I looked
at him and said no I'm actually here to
save your company I'm part of the
marketing firm and man you guys need
help I can't believe you didn't run me
out of that room but he didn't all of
them left we sat down and I had a seat
at the table the CEO was incredibly
supportive I had a lot to say I gave a
lot of feedback and by the end that
robotics firm didn't hire them they
hired us me and the CEO and so it was a
really important moment for me of again
recognizing how I was being perceived
being facing up to that challenge and
then responding away that to me
celebrated who I was for better for
worse so while I was at this tech
marketing firm as you can imagine they
used to fly me out here a lot right
because there was so much innovation
happening in California specifically in
the valley and I fell in love with
Northern California and so I walked into
our CEOs room one day his off
one day and I said I think I'm moving to
San Francisco I know you don't want me
to I know we don't have an office there
but I think I want to do that and he
looked at me and said go start her
office out there so I came out here
started the office out here brought in
some clients out here and then a
wonderful thing to date myself happened
sarcastically I say everything started
to fall apart
this was the era of the pink slips this
was the era of the shutdowns this was
the last dot-com bust and so as someone
who loves technology and was building a
tech practice it wasn't a great time to
be here so I called the CEO and I shared
this with him and I said very
transparently here's what's going on out
here
I know you in New York probably don't
have the same viewpoint vantage point
but this is what's happening and I don't
think it's responsible of me to continue
like this so here's a couple ways we can
work together but truly my
recommendation is wine this down and so
as we were kind of negotiating that
together I thought to myself well now
what I just moved myself out to San
Francisco with a job I thought I had the
economy's tanking in front of me what am
I gonna do now and so I spent some time
thinking through all right I love being
out here I could do anything what would
I do and what I realized is what I
really wanted to do was take everything
I have learned working on Madison Avenue
New York working with high-caliber
clients and everything I had learned
working for community development over
the years and see if I could build
bridges and so I ended up getting a
really cool job at what is now
considered a social enterprise and so at
the time there was a consortium built in
San Francisco to bring in formerly
homeless individuals back into the
workforce by training them through
technology and I thought that was
awesome and so my role was to build a
bridge was try to get large corporations
to care about what we were doing and so
I would go into Wells and I would go
into city and I would go into Genentech
and I would talk to all these large
corporations and say don't you care look
how the homelessness situation in San
Fran
go look at the tech campus that we've
created we can get people back into the
workforce
don't you care don't you want to join us
and you won't be shocked by the answer
the answer is no they didn't I'm sure
people did
I'm sure individuals did but as a
corporate firm that wasn't their chief
motive that wasn't their you know
operational goal and so I decided to
take a different approach I started
interviewing these corporations and I
said well what do you care about what
are your pain points what's actually
hard for your job and what I learned was
while they didn't really care about the
nonprofit side of what we were doing
they had a diversity problem they could
not get enough diversity candidates and
so I said well if I could get some
incredible diversity candidates for you
do you care where they came from
nope and so I created a diversity
recruitment agency out of this nonprofit
100% for-profit totally motivate
motivated by these corporate recruiters
desire to bring in recruit check you
know diverse candidates but got hundreds
of diversity candidates jobs just by
changing the positioning and so at the
time I was working very closely with the
board including the vice president of
Goodwill Industries and he took me aside
you said hey cat you know what you just
did write this recruitment agency you
just built that's getting all these
people jobs
that's called a social enterprise that's
called The Social Venture totally new to
me was not a common phrase at the time
but I instantly knew that's what I
wanted to do and so I helped build that
out I passed it to a director and I went
back to get my MBA and thought there's
still a lot I need to know if I'm gonna
do this and do it again and again and
again and so I ended up going back to
business school to get mine be a very
focus and I chose Oxford because at the
time the Oxford School Center was known
for really nurturing social
entrepreneurs
as I went back there to get my MBA to
learn enough to be dangerous and to be
able to build social ventures at scale
based on fundamental business principles
but providing social good amazing time
at Oxford ended up rolling out a couple
other initiatives I think there's
probably I realized I just love building
things and when I left as most of you
will experience I face that fork in the
road of what do you do do I go get that
corporate job do I go build a social
enterprise unfortunately I had no choice
I had a big fat student debt and so I
opted for management consulting I was
part of the strategy division did a lot
of work in Latin America first while
feeling what I really want to do is
build social ventures and so on the side
I started my second social venture which
is now called global brigades or G being
I always tell people one of the hardest
things that I do not recommend is you
having an 80 hour work week management
consulting job and building a startup on
the side do not recommend until I became
a mom and then hey get away you know
what I really don't recommend kidding so
it was crazy
and it was a lot but we did it and
actually within the first year my
co-founder and I grew so fast that we
quit our day jobs
absolutely quit management consulting
and did GB full-time incredible ride we
are able to build an initiative that
really linked students who are looking
to do social good with an opportunity to
build a resume an opportunity to get
real-life working experience an
opportunity to experience a new type of
environment abroad and we built it from
one campus to ten campuses to hundreds
of campuses to ten students to a hundred
students to now thousands of students
it's now in five countries
it's the largest global student
development firm in the world and it was
an incredible ride and at any every
point in the journey there was so many
critical times where I had to pick
whether I wanted to go the normal path
the path of majority or the path of
other so at a certain point about four
and a half years in we grew very large
multi-million dollar and I was ready to
exit my co-founder was not and so we had
a heart-to-heart and I could tell he
just wanted to do this for the rest of
his life and so I said okay I support
that I will sit on your board we can
talk about exiting in a different stage
but I get this you want another five
years of this ride I get it I'm ready to
see my next chapter so I ended up taking
a board seat and now I was right back to
this what am I gonna do now and so like
many entrepreneurs you know in the
valley I ended up going into venture
capital not for the same reasons I think
you probably have heard others speak
about because to me the reason I wanted
to go into venture had nothing to do
with Sand Hill Road or anytime of a
romanticism because at the time being a
woman adventurer and yes we know this
hasn't changed much it was not very
glamorous right it was actually tough
but the reason I chose to go to the
venture side of the equation the capital
side of the equation is I started to get
fascinated by money as a flow of energy
money as a source of power what we do
with capital how capital moves
throughout our country and throughout
our world starting to fascinate me and
then seeing it captured by this industry
called venture capital and how they were
using it as an instrument for change
fascinated me and so the tape that was
playing in the back of my head was if
this is tremendous energy tremendous
power could this not be a source for
change could this not be an instrument
for positive social change and so I
spent about four years on the venture
side I led deal flow for a global firm I
started their angel fun excellent
experience I got to work with a lot of
both typical entrepreneurs social
entrepreneurs you name it
and then got a very interesting
opportunity to work and run a division
of Charles Schwab so I got to work it
with a strategy group at Schwab based on
data and their idea this is a new group
the premise was we've got tons of data
as a financial services firm we're
trying to understand what the future of
Finance is gonna look like specifically
when we think about this large wealth
transfer that's about to happen led by
women and Millennials what is that going
to look like for major financial
services
I just spent years looking at FinTech
companies and other companies the firm I
looked at was very focused on women's
empowerment and so I was a pretty likely
candidate for that group and I thought
it was a really interesting challenge
okay let's see how money flows how this
energy goes in a big financial services
firm and they're probably not shocking
to most of you I found some pretty
interesting findings one was not much
was gonna change anytime soon I have
incredible respect for my colleagues at
Schwab it's to date one of the best
large companies I've ever worked for the
issue being most of these large firms
are stuck in legacy systems in old
business models and focuses that aren't
going to change because of the
governance body and so despite me
presenting all the data in the world on
what this wealth transfer could look
like and the products and services we
could be thinking about and bringing to
fruition nothing was gonna change
anytime soon and so I sat with that
reality for bit as I worked there and
one night I was sitting on my couch
looking at my own financials online
banking and I discovered that I had cash
just sitting there several thousands of
dollars non emergency fund just stupid
cash sitting in my bank account and here
I'm supposed to be this finance person
right managing director at Charles
Schwab running this group focused on the
future of Finance and yet I'm being
silly with my money
and so I kind of took a pause back and
thought to myself I wonder why I do this
and I wonder if I'm alone in doing this
and so there I started on this journey
looking at where others doing this same
thing that I was doing which I call
forgotten dollars were people just
leaving money on the sidelines not
putting it in the market not putting
another investment vehicles literally
keeping it in our checking and savings
accounts and what I will share with you
may be shocking for some of you
Americans sit on over 300 billion
dollars of these Forgotten dollars
that's billion with a B so it wasn't
alone in this behavioral pattern and the
light that happened in my head was
billions of dollars collecting just in
our checking and savings doing no good
for us but also no good for our
communities if we could unpack unleash
even a portion of that 300 billion
dollars I want you to think about what
kind of good we could do in this country
the schools we could fund the community
centers we could fund the minority led
businesses we could fund all of the
things we all talk about collectively if
things we feel passionate about or feel
that there is injustice when it comes to
capital what if we could unpack some of
those dollars for some of those things
and that began my journey of c-note so
seeing cash and seeing finance as an
instrument for change I shared this
wacky idea of building a new suite of
investment products they came with very
very different intention intention to
give back competitive return to those of
us who work so hard for those dollars
and to make sure that when you go to
sleep at night those dollars are going
to work in a way that you feel proud of
and building the type of tomorrow that
you want to see and so I met up with a
dear friend of mine who former Wall
Street executive had just got back from
Kenya working in finance building
products that made
created positive social impact and I
pitched this idea to her and I'm
fortunate to say she was into it and so
together my friend and what mazing
co-founder Yulia joined together to
create what is now our FinTech company
see know I share that longer journey
because so much of what we were trying
to do at cenote has to do with this
experience of other what I take away
from those years of feeling different or
feeling out or trying to fit in is one
very key attribute bridge building able
to build bridges so just like in my
first social enterprise I was able to
connect connect corporate America with
these formally homeless centers and
nonprofits we are seeking and driving
forward the ability to connect
traditional financial services with
social innovation so you can imagine
what it feels like to be a woman in
finance I won't belabor this point not
much has changed there's some incredible
women now at the table but we still have
a long way to go and so every time that
you Lee and I are the only woman on a
panel or the only woman at it at a
finance conference or the only innovator
trying to redesign financial products
not just package it not just pink it and
shrink it but truly redesign financial
products we feel like this but we know
we're doing the right thing one of the
things we feel very passionate about at
Sina is creating that sense of community
and future where all others can feel
recognized so we started our first
product which is a savings product we
said we were going to dress cash and we
created this 40 X savings product but
instrumental to us in that creation was
to build bridges for two parties one was
to make sure that
that money that is just sitting in our
checking and savings is actually going
to work for our communities and doing
tremendous good
that's absolutely part of our social
mission and fundamental the second part
is making sure that everyone has access
to those financial products because what
both of us found working in financial
services that there were so many cool
things being spoken about a few of them
actually being created and then when
they are created they were available for
this many people if you were high
net-worth
if you could afford a financial advisor
lots of creative vehicles for you if
you're a college student you're just
graduated not so much so the second
piece of our mission as a company is to
make sure all of the products that we
create that do good and provide a
competitive return are accessible to
everybody no minimum no fees you get it
it's been a long road it's been an
exciting road but I will tell you I've
never felt more proud to be a woman in
finance to be a woman innovator to be a
woman entrepreneur and to be a woman
learner I think so much of the
experience I've had of feeling different
and then embracing that different has
taught me how to stand up in the face of
adversity has given me the opportunity
to shine that light that I shared and
reflect about reflect on the person that
I want it to be and the type of
entrepreneur I wanted to share and stand
up for the things that I believe in and
so I'll leave you on this note from a
very personal personal experience I have
two kids my sons now five and the other
day as I was leaving the house he says
to me mom what are you go to work my
friend's mom stay home every day you're
racing out a year going to work
why do you do that and I kneeled by his
side and I said to him because I believe
that everyone has a gift and when you
have
and purpose and can reflect and enjoy
that gift I call that work and so when I
go every day and do what I do
didn't it enlightens me it invigorates
me and it feels like I'm sharing my gift
and so I say to each of you tonight I
know each of you have a gift to share
and if you ever ever get that feeling of
other give me a call I'm happy to share
that my other sees your other and I
think you're extraordinary thank you
[Applause]
yes agreed so how would you change that
people coming out of my knowledge larger
question but I think the question you're
getting at is around financial education
and there's been tremendous studies and
sorry for those this is gonna piss off
but there's been a lot of studies that
indicate that a lot of our best
financial literacy programs are failures
that they don't actually work and part
of it starts from a premise that I
believe which is we've created most
financial products and most financial
literacy programs expecting us to be
rational human beings and we're not
rational human beings and so what we
work on is how do you bring back the
emotion and behaviorism into finance you
don't see a lot of it but that's what
we're working towards and so my answer
to your questions we actually been
looking and working with behavioral
economists to look at that issue not
just the timing of when do you start
because a lot of folks say high schools
too late College is too late to start
those conversations of understanding
money and the flow of money and and you
know finance and financial resources but
then the how we actually get people to
interact it and get positive behaviors
we talk about gamification we talk about
social circles and and social norms and
so I think there's a long-winded answer
to you is we're working on it the answer
is not clear but I'm inspired to see
that we're moving away from the 50 years
of you know just read this and you'll be
fine as long as you understand
I'm sure you'll go do it too that's not
how we operate and so how do we build
programs and services and interactions
that make people more thoughtful very
early on about their dollars and how
they utilize them so it's a great
question and we're working on it mm-hmm
yes how can an undergrad you just get
involved with you know
thank you thank you we had an amazing
intern this summer from MIT who said the
same thing and he just you know blew me
away in terms of so many ideas so I
would say there's tons of ways
definitely come up to me after anyone is
feel free to email me it's cat CAT at my
scene Oh calm and let me know you're
interested but I love the question
because one of the things we talked
about relates to your question is how do
we get people to start early the reason
we decided to have no fees and no
minimums and access was so that
everybody could get in and start feeling
what it's like to earn more to you know
just as people very very wealthy where
anymore you get to earn more - and also
know your money is doing something
really powerful to feel that early on
not ten years from now not thirty years
from out but now and so we're working on
programs right now specifically College
ambassador programs and so happy to
tease that out but definitely would love
to to chat more about it thank you other
questions
you can access their incredible minds
did you find now in what you're doing
that they're interested in the approach
here now see did you see that sort of
reflected is sort of but one of the
things we always talk about it's in
large organization this idea that
they're kind of stuck in this modality
yeah and then they see others like
running free right and space and they go
cheap yeah I think one theme that we
hear it not just that schwa but most of
the other peers is about the transfer of
wealth so the idea that the vast
majority of people that used to run you
know own the wealth or own assets in
this country where white males and
that's about to change and in the next
twenty years a historic shift is a-comin
and there's no financial service for am
I've spoken with MIT denies it in fact
they're all internally talking about it
and they're all trying to figure it out
what do you do when your whole firm is
based on the notion of serving ex-client
and yet you know in the next ten years
that client looks and acts completely
different you probably know some of
these statistics but when you think
about women and herring a great portion
of that wealth for three reasons one
traditionally women live longer so they
end up inheriting their husbands wealth
two women are working more so they end
up having their own wealth right and in
three the wealth that's happening from
parents many more parents are actually
in a position to to pass down wealth to
these same women so these women have a
trifecta of inheritance coming or wealth
coming to them and yet a financial
services community that is not used to
working with them we were just at a big
finance conference called money 2020
this week in Las Vegas and the CEO of
Accenture shared this statistic that ten
percent of women in America feel like
financial services care about them we
also know that
over 70% of women fire their financial
adviser when their husband passes away
or when they get divorced and so there's
a lot of problems in terms of how we're
treating not just women I would argue I
would say people of color and anyone
who's of a certain age I remember going
into banks when I was 20 25 very little
attention very little speaking my
language very few products you know I
wanted to work with and so I don't think
it's just a woman issue I think it's a
business model focus issue it's about to
change whether they like it or not and
so one of the things we're trying to
shine a light on is exactly that how do
we create a future to inherit those
dollars and put them to work for good if
we can redesign finance what would that
look like and I think we have that
opportunity other questions yes can you
elaborate on how we came up with the 2.5
percent versus 2 or 3 and then you see
this company mix yeah great question so
the question was how do we come up with
two and a half percent which I love that
question we actually came up with a
higher percentage and and again we came
we started with the premise of you work
hard for those dollars and those dollars
are making 0% and the institution that's
benefiting from your hard work are these
large financial institutions it's
business model and so what could I give
you back that's gonna feel fair to you
and put that money to work for you so it
started with that the second piece is
the underlying asset not to get into
crazy jargon works with a a
asset known as C deifies an asset in an
industry and so when working with them
we had to model it out to work with what
was going to be reasonable for them to
put to work what was going to be
reasonable for us as a firm and what
could I pass back to you and so that was
part of the science that we did to see
can we make it sustainable can we make
it guaranteed can we bright and really
make it pop so I spoke to someone when
we were first doing our public beta and
I shared with her very smart woman what
we were doing and she said Kat why would
you do too
half-percent that's way beyond what
anyone expects give it one point one
given one point two I mean she was
really trying to talk me down to like
you know get to like an ally or a
Capital One savings rate because she
said you know this is so far beats
what's out there why would you do that
and that's when I shared with her I said
because we can and I think the more gets
getting back to other the more we try to
fit in or just slightly iterate I think
it's a lost opportunity we're trying to
make a statement financial products
don't have to look like this feel like
this only operate for a chosen few and
so it was very intentional that we went
bigger than we had to and then the
second piece was where do we plan to be
correct yeah so a couple answers to that
number one we plan to drive billions of
dollars into our economy so 300 billion
is just retail is just meaning what's in
our checking and savings accounts doing
nothing for us you go to the
institutional side and it's over a
trillion so there's a lot of cash
sitting on the sidelines that could be
working for our communities and so one
one answer to that is we are planning to
drive several billions of dollars into
schools minority entrepreneurs women
entrepreneurs community centers that's a
function of what we do the second piece
of that is to become a major player in
terms of financial products again the
thought being I don't want my kids to
know there wasn't this as an option I
want them to laugh at the fact that
banks used to get away with giving a 0%
laugh at the fact that those dollars
would sit and go to work for banks and
not our local communities we're striving
to make this the norm other question
last question yeah it's fairly fairly
guaranteed
state and federal guarantees but we're
not a bank so to be very clear c-note is
not a bank we are not an ally we are not
a Wells Fargo and because we're not a
depository institution yeah so the
insurance is not provided through FDIC
so we work with federal and state
guarantee programs that come with GD
advice come with our CDFI actually it
doesn't come at all sing advised so yeah
longer conversation so CDFI which is the
underlying asset is called Community
Development financial institutions I
encourage you to all look them up it's
been around for over 20 years they were
created by the US Treasury Department
all of the CDF eyes are certified by the
US Treasury Department and it's a
construct or an asset class that every
major bank already uses so every bank or
Dean uses them for solid return and
solid impact it's just you and I didn't
get access to them
we didn't very high thresholds didn't
have the legal framework very
diversified decentralized group so these
are all the problems that we had to
solve for to create what we can now give
you as two and a half percent the great
question and one of the reasons I love
CDFI that they've been there done that
so again these guys have been around for
over 20 years many of them 30 40 years
they've seen several recessions and so
one of the things we got to do before we
tried this was model out what would
another recession look like and what did
the last two recessions look like and
they actually outperformed FDIC
institutions it's a great question okay
I think that's it
you